Será que aquela sua cólica menstrual é
realmente só uma cólica? Olha só o caso
dessa australiana de 22 anos que quase
pagou caro por ignorar os sinais. Pois
é, a Charlotte passou meses achando que
era TPM, sabe? Inchaço, dor na barriga,
até que uma amiga insistiu para ela
procurar um médico. Resultado, ela tinha
câncer de testino grosso, estágio 3, com
22 anos. Os próprios médicos duvidaram
no começo porque ela era muito jovem.
Veja bem, o nosso corpo não mente se
você tem cólicas que não passam, sangue
nas feeses, mudança no hábito
intestinal, inchaço constante, isso não
é normal não. O câncer de intestino em
jovem está aumentando muito,
principalmente por causa da alimentação
ultraprocessada, sedentarismo e outros
motivos extremamente polêmicos. E olha,
quando aparece sintoma, muitas vezes já
tá avançado. Então fica a dica. Dor
persistente merece investigação. A
Charlote se salvou porque alguém
insistiu. E você vai esperar alguém
insistir?